[Music]
container registry is a private
container image registry that runs on
google cloud
this quick start shows you how to build
a docker image and how to push and pull
the image from your project's container
registry all from the command line
before you begin make sure that one you
have a google cloud project selected
two billing and the container registry
api are enabled and three you have the
cloud sdk and docker installed on your
docker file
which provides information on how to
package application two
requirements.txt
is used to list your application and
dependencies
three
app.pi is the actual python code of your
application
run the docker build command to create a
docker image on your local machine
next we'll configure docker to use the
gcloud command line tool to authenticate
requests to container registry using the
gcloud auth command now we use the
docker tag command to associate the
docker image with a registry name so
that we can push the image to a specific
location
we can now upload the docker image to
container registry with the docker push
command
you can view images hosted by container
registry via the google cloud console or
by visiting the images registry name in
your web browser
to pull the image from container
registry on your local machine run the
docker pool command
finally you can delete the docker image
from container registry using the gcloud
container images delete command
you